&gt;&gt; How does this sort of work into the design process? I mean, I've heard of
this thing rapid prototyping, how does that, what's that all mean as far as 3D
printing. &gt;&gt; The real hindrance with 3D printing right now is scale. It's very
cost prohibitive to print things like that are very large and scale. We have a
motor cycle in the gallery. But, that's pretty big print and it took a lot of
time and so there's this other idea out there called rapid prototyping and there
you see products like one, two, three make things that take very large objects
like this elephant. Or last year refer maker fair we did a 12 foot tall trojan
horse out of cardboard. &gt;&gt; And it takes those big elements and it takes them out
into folded panels or it takes them like as you can see in the octopus in the
background into sliced cardboard cutouts. So we can use something like a laser
cutter to make things very larger very quickly. &gt;&gt; So it's just a matter of
time, so right, I usually think of three D printing because, since you're doing
layer by layer by layer, that can take a while. &gt;&gt; Yeah. &gt;&gt; The higher
resolution you have, I would think the more layers you have to put down. &gt;&gt; Yeah
its a really interesting time too because the high end 3D printers are extremely
high res and very slow [laugh] and very high cost. In the consumer grade
printers, things like a maker bot or a typing machine they're extremely low res
and very fast [laugh] but their cost is kind of going up and the high res stuff,
the cost is kind of going down so I think the next couple of years, we're going
to see a meet in the middle. And you're going to end up with this great device
that almost anybody can use and give you know, a print that is very usable for
multiple things.